do you still have the same view of
Sundance now after having run a
successful festival for 20 years well
first of all thank you very much for
calling Slamdance a successful festival
oh that's very generous of you know I i
think i think sundance has gotten a lot
of the criticisms that we had about them
the first year they've addressed I mean
they show more film so they show more
films by first-time directors so you
know I mean I I still think it's you
know well we still do our programming
differently than they do and organized
differently and that's okay but I think
what's interesting is that a lot of
filmmakers you come to slam dances
first-time directors then go to Sundance
for their second film or they'll show
that shorted Slamdance you know like
Napoleon Dynamite it was a short at slam
dance and then the next year it was a
feature at Sundance and I think that's
fine you know I think that's great and I
think Sundance has started to figure
that out a little bit too that you know
so many of their directors that have
been consistently winning prizes and
playing their films there have some
connection to sign that's one way or the
other whether it's Tiffany Shlain who
showed her first film or or Lynn Shelton
or Drake Doremus who were both you know
award-winning directors its lands for
the first films so so I think it's the
coexist a little bit smoother now also
the people running it now like us a
little more than the people running it
back then and and even Redford himself I
mean he called his parasites early on
and he was right but but I think he you
know when people ask him now he's like
oh yeah miss Lana it's it's you know
definitely has its place and I think you
know for better for worse you know the
whole park city experience has gotten a
lot crazier but it's not really
sundance's fault it's like all the it's
it's all the gifting suites and
Corporate ization of Main Street where
people just these companies come in and
they just rent out these restaurants and
gallery spaces and condos and whatever
and that money isn't going to sundance
and it's not going
Seether and you know and that's brought
a lot of the celebrity culture and the
paparazzi there which has not
necessarily been good for for Sundance
or for us but I think to their credit
Sundance realized that's a much bigger
problem than us like they really like
we're okay you know well you know that's
a much bigger deal that's who they
should be you know and they know that's
who they ideally would like to run out
of town much more than us at least we're
showing films you know and talking about
films so so I think there's you know
there's sort of institutional problems I
have nothing to do with us you know and
yeah is that under the guise of nothing
bonds like a common enemy or do you
think that they feel that you've earned
your stripes uh I think they feel like
we've earned our stripes like we've
we've stuck with it long enough like
we're not just the flash in the pan like
me you stick around 20 years like these
guys aren't going anywhere you know so
they I think they get that now and
that's fine and and as I say I think you
know I don't know if they notice it as
much as we notice it but there have been
so many alumni that have come from
slamming into Sundance and I think
what's interesting is I think when they
have played at Slane rats first they do
better at Sundance they literally know
the scene they hit the ground running
they know how to make flyers and posters
and you know run around Park City and
where this is and where that is and you
know a'kla mated to the altitude and
have the park and ready to go and I
think because of that people like you
know Lynn Shelton and Drake Doremus you
know when they get to parks you know
when they get to some dance they do
better there because I've had that first
experience with us
you